the woman who was jailed when she has
like a
child and a breastfeeding kid because
she called a trans woman a man
she shouldn't have been jailed it's
ma'am you saw that video too yes i did
now is that a slur i'm making fun of it
no no no i feel like
trans women aren't oppressed well he
feels that way they feel that way that
they're they're a language they're all
white men
for the most part what if it's a black
transgender who wins the oppression
olympics if it's a black transgender
with rickets
time for some bonus footage from the
recent change my mind at ut
austin now remember this changed my mind
setup was a bit different we first let
the students debate on a number of
different topics
but i did eventually sit down with some
students myself in the more traditional
format as you'll see here
since the 4th of july is right around
the corner i wanted to include this
conversation with elise about why
america is superior to
all other countries watch enjoy and let
me know in the comments section below
what it is that you believe
makes the united states the greatest
country in the world happy fourth
all right what's your name i'm elise
elise i'm sorry to hear that you were
hit by a scooter yes i was earlier
so we weren't even discussing this today
we just didn't happen to have the build
the wall poster
but seemed like you were passionate
about this i do stand by it i do believe
that the united states is the greatest
country in the world
um and if you disagree with me you're
more than welcome to change my mind at
least okay i will
say i do think america is great i just
think there are some things that make it
not the greatest in the world maybe on
par with some other countries but not
greater than them okay so which
countries would you say are greater than
the united states and why uh
probably countries that have universal
health care and stuff like that
i feel like that's a big issue with
america so like could you name me some
countries
like canada and england and stuff
what happened to someone throw something
at you no they started laughing oh
that's okay that happens
i know usually when i say something dumb
yeah so it's okay
uh so canada or the uk yes do you
believe that or did you say canada or
england specifically
uh i said uk basically yeah
so and and all those uh they're talking
do you believe they're better than the
united states not better but i think the
us
is on par with them i don't think any of
them
are greater than like the other
because i feel like i mean i just don't
think america can be called the
most superior country on earth when
people are dying because they can't
afford medication
uh i do
yeah for a couple of reasons not only
because our care is better than those
countries
by the way did you know that i'm
canadian i was raised in montreal oh
nice so uh you know the death the death
rates the survival rates of serious
diseases in these uh
in these countries particularly in the
uk seven times higher if you have a
serious disease or being in an emergency
room than it is in the united states
the wait times depending on the
parameters that use can be anywhere from
two times as long to four times as long
the health care outcomes are not better
in these countries
and by the way they're largely beholden
to us providing
national security effectively for the
whole world because i don't have to
burden that cost
so not only do i believe that um
obviously our health care system is
flawed
but not only do i believe that our
health care system is superior to those
countries particularly the country
uh from which i migrated to canada to
the united states
but there would be another reason
outside of healthcare let's assume that
healthcare were better in those
countries
freedom is a big one how can a country
be better
than the united states if they don't
allow freedom to their citizens
i don't think america really allows
freedom to their citizens either all the
way
because once once you've committed a
crime
your rights are stripped from you right
but we we do assume that everyone we
give everyone grant everyone sorry not
give we don't give any rights we grant
um or recognize the term i should use
here i want to pick my words very
carefully
recognize god-given rights to human
beings here in this country that no
other country recognizes
namely uh freedom of speech is a big one
that doesn't exist in those countries
that you just mentioned
is that not a biggie i feel like freedom
of speech is very important
but at the same time it's like
this is getting into the whole like
freedom of speech hate speech thing
right
like no no i mean like with freedom of
speech being an important thing i feel
like
there are certain things that are like
more important than others
okay so what's more important than the
first amendment
well what rights are more important than
the the freedom of assembly
uh the free freedom of speech freedom of
the press what rights would you say
are more important for a government to
recognize the right to life
okay that's also something that we
recognize yes but not
entirely if you're if there if you are
too broke
then apparent then america just doesn't
recognize your right life
they might say they do but then it's you
can't afford insulin
okay you're gonna die now you can't
afford
this medical procedure okay you're gonna
die right
i think um your misunderstanding here
the difference between rights
and commodities right you have the right
to live you have the right to seek the
best health
care possible for yourself you do not
have the right to
force someone else to provide you with
health care you do not have the right to
have somebody else create invest go
through red tape and fda approval
process
study become a doctor go to medical
school get hundreds of thousands of
dollars into debt
and force them to provide you with
medical uh procedures
or drugs simply because you can't afford
them that is not a right
that's a good that's a commodity but
that's the thing is i think
that should be a right you should it
doesn't mean that it is
you should have the right but that's
exactly what i'm saying though that's
why america is not superior the most
superior because they don't see that as
a right
sure but we do see see i would say this
maybe we just won't be able to agree
um freedom of speech to me is more
important i think that's a much more
valuable
fundamental right than forcing somebody
else to give me free health care
you disagree with that well i feel like
because i do feel like freedom of speech
is an amazing thing
it's great that we're able to sit down
and talk and have debates on whatever we
want
because we have that right right but it
doesn't exist in these other countries
we wouldn't be able to do this
but i do believe like there's just a
huge flaw
in the fact that people are dying
because they cannot afford things
but more people are dying in these other
countries because their health care
systems are worse
but the mortality rates the survival
rates of diseases like cancer terminal
diseases not to mention the diseases
that are not being cured in these other
countries
the major uh major treatments are coming
out of the united states because of
medical innovation and research which
doesn't occur occur under a socialized
system
so if you're talking about people dying
because of healthcare
more people are dying because of lack of
access to good care
under socialized health care systems
than the united states no system is
perfect
but are you willing to give up your
freedom of speech
your second amendment rights but let's
just go with freedom of speech you're
willing to give that up
for a worse health care outlook overall
provided that it's given to you at
gunpoint by another taxpayer
if i wasn't allowed to say certain
things like
if i wasn't allowed to
i feel like there are things that people
shouldn't be allowed to say
okay is the thing so you don't support
the first so freedom of speech is not
necessarily something to support now
this okay
i don't necessarily support people
people shouldn't be allowed to say
uh like people shouldn't be able to say
do not say fire in a crowded theater
please
i mean like that yeah definitely not but
that is technically like that incites
a riot like that's already not like you
could already get in trouble for saying
yes
that's not because of speech just
because it's a lie yeah yeah
but i feel like people shouldn't be able
to like we already have restrictions on
freedom of speech here you're not
allowed to incite violence against
people
like it's like that's not a restriction
it's
like in a crowd you're not allowed to
like
you're trying to think of an example
it's not saying fire aren't you no
i'm not that's but that's what everyone
says
i'm trying to think of you're not
you shouldn't be allowed to like
i shouldn't be allowed to go around
calling people the n-word
because that's a slur like that's a
that's not something i should be allowed
to say
why not because that's an offensive word
that's a slur it's an offensive word
absolutely
someone just called me a idiot
right should should i be able to have
these guys haul them away in cuffs
well no i don't think cuffs is that's a
that's
well what do you do what do you mean you
shouldn't be allowed to say it what
should the ramifications by the way
people shouldn't walk around calling
black people the n-word okay i don't
want i think we both agree on that but
you said people shouldn't be allowed to
i think why not because that's just
that's not okay like it's not nice so
what would you do to someone who uses
the n-word what should be done
there should be like a small fine or
something like to like
deter them from saying that like people
shouldn't be allowed to call me
like that's a slur i think people should
be allowed to i think it's mean
it's a word that's been used to oppress
lesbians for like years like that's
like it shouldn't be allowed you
shouldn't be allowed to call a gay
person
that's like not okay why not
saying it's not okay or that it's wrong
or that it's offensive
doesn't mean that it's not a right it's
like
those words have been used in oppressing
these people
for like a very long time okay
it's kind of like it's
those for example yeah people who were
in position the n-word people who
weren't
i want to make sure that we understand
and kind of save us some time for
example with the n-word people in
positions of power
not only plantation owners but people in
government right who supported slavery
and positions of power use the n-word as
a way to
um degrade and assert their power over
black
people right yes okay so these are
people in government people in positions
of authority who use this term
um why would you want to grant the right
to legislate language
to people in positions of power or
authority i just feel like
you're giving that power away to the
patriarchy those words specifically
dehumanize people
sure but the point is someone is going
to be determining what language is
allowed or not
right you want to give that right over
to the government
maybe not you want donald trump to
determine i don't want donald trump okay
so
donald trump should be the president
well who cares so the point i feel like
that's part of why america isn't
superior because of trump
but the point is right now it's going to
go straight to the top you want him in
charge of language no i feel like it
should be like a national vote
like that's what i think so do you
believe that all rights come from a
national vote
well no but i feel like certain things
should
well okay let me give give you this as
an example um in these other countries
like canada where i come from you have
comedians who've been jailed for
offensive jokes
uh there's actually a friend of mine
named mike ward uh who was put before
human rights tribunal and i believed
fined
150 000 or 50 000 for a joke that
offended a kid from a make-a-wish
foundation
you have people who are arrested left
and right in europe
um in the uk there was a man who was
actually i believe fine because he was
doing a cover of kung fu
fighting at a karaoke bar and an asian
person said that it was offensive to him
when you have the government determining
what language is and
is not acceptable that's a very
dangerous
precedent to set where's the line what
you find offensive might not be
offensive to someone else what someone
else finds offensive who may be in power
for those four years maybe completely
acceptable to you why
why would you support giving that right
over to the government furthermore
most movements civil rights movements
the lgbt movement right the
gay pride movement these movements have
been created by people who would be
presumed to be underclass or the
oppressed right
and they did it through language they
did it non-violently
they got legislation passed why would
you want to strip them
of their language or grant the authority
to the government to strip minorities of
their language
that's the i'm saying that we should
make it to where people that aren't of
the minority can't
call the people of the minority slurs
against that minority
but minorities majorities change all the
time right that's the whole point to a
constitutional republic to protect the
rights of the minority
from a majority anytime you grant the
government
the right to legislate speech it ends
badly it's never ended well
so i just want to make sure that maybe
we can move on to another issue of
discussion
you believe that these countries are
better than the united states because
they have socialized health care
and it seems to me like you believe that
they're better than the united states
because they don't have freedom of
speech
well no i wouldn't say that i mean like
i feel like
no country has done freedom of speech
stuff correctly
i'll say that i would say the united
states because like
i'll say like the woman who is jailed be
when she has like a
child and a breastfeeding kid because
she called a trans woman a man
she shouldn't have been jailed like
that's not okay like
i feel like there's a like
it's ma'am
you saw that video too yes i did now is
that a slur i'm making fun of that guy
no no no i feel like
but he does trans women aren't oppressed
well he feels that way
they feel that way their languages white
men for the most part what if it's a
black transgender
they're meant for who wins who wins the
oppression olympics if it's a black
transgender with rickets
the point is you can't deter these this
is the problem with identity politics
right
you just said well no no hold on a
second so uh
because he's a white man he's not
oppressed well he thinks that
and you have these bills you have these
pieces of legislation that are being
proposed
that would outlaw misgendering people i
mean you see that in canada
that's an awful thing why is it all not
that's not a
question they see it as oppression
because someone called them the wrong
gender i've i've been called a dude
before multiple times
i don't know why maybe that was a guy
was hitting you on the scooter could
have been drunk i would never confuse
you for a dude
but like that's so what like that's not
the same as like someone tried to like
someone but they want to literally take
your rights away
they want to do the exact same thing to
you that you want to do
to people who might use the word or
understand
but they've been hit with someone
calling them a [ __ ] or they've been
hit with god forbid
being called a man being called a man
instead of ma'am
the point is they want to do the exact
same thing to you remove
your right to speak as you would do with
other people
do you see the danger in that and who
determines that life there is a danger
in it but i feel like the thing is
really it just comes down to
in the most part like people just don't
care about each other is the thing like
that's why i feel like there should be
regulations
okay it doesn't seem like you're super
clear on what the regulation should be
at this point
it's a very fine line to walk is the
thing
i don't think it's a very hard thing
like i don't think it is i i would
i would fight uh with every fiber of my
being your right to say whatever it is
that you want to say
offensive or not as i would hope people
would fight for my right to say it i
believe free speech is absolute
i do not believe that places like the uk
or countries like my uh
place where i was raised in canada have
it right i think they have it wrong
i think it's an atrocity i think it's a
violation of human rights one of the
most fundamental human rights
and i think that far and away is what
makes the united states the greatest
country in the world
along with also really good healthcare
in a kick-ass military
but thank you so much elise elise thank
you elise
i really appreciate it thank you for
being civil and i'm sorry that someone
hit with a speeder a
speeder a scooter and called you a name
i would never do that
usa usa usa
usa usa oh you're still here i'll chalk
that up to our fantastic retention rate
if you enjoyed this installment of
change my mind please consider clicking
on one of these boxes i can't see where
they are to watch another installment or
i'd highly recommend considering uh
joining my club at lido's credit.com
mug club not only do you get access to
the full daily show and content that you
can't see here on youtube
but because we were recently entirely
demonetized it's the only thing that
keeps this kind of content
going so we appreciate your support as
public enemy number one of youtube
we're learning how to navigate these
waters maybe if we were
more effective at transgender makeup
tutorials or more advertiser friendly
podcast
about transgender makeup tutorials